Okay, thank you. We have
Vibe Coding at Scale. It's a talk I'm
going to give at the Expo in a very
short version without all the hands-on
stuff. So, this is whatever how long
this will take.
It's all about Vibe Coding. So, we're
going to give fully in to the vibes,
embrace exponential, and forget that
code exists.
It is about focusing on the output
and not actually on the code. And that's
where where people disagree. Like, if I
don't look at my code as an engineer,
what am I?
And then if
what is even embracing exponentials mean
in this case?
So, and that's we're going to get into
that. And but we're definitely going to
forget that code exists. And I think the
at the Entropic conference 2 weeks ago
was a great chart of how exponentially
agents run longer and longer and
generate more and more code.
So, slowly forgetting that code exists
and you want to review every piece of
code, but building trust and adding
guardrails to the AI
is what this talk is about.
And as Vibe Coding journey starts kind
of
initially what most people saw of just
like I build an app in just 1 day and I
put it online and I made money and I
then things happened to the app and
things got leaked and
things were no longer fun. And that
could that's that fun chaos state of
Vibe Coding. And we're trying to move to
professionals then. And that initial
state is what I'm now terming YOLO
vibes. It's the unofficial wording, but
it's all about creativity and speed.
And it's a good place to be. It's like
it's there is instant gratification.
It's getting things up. It's about
learning.
It's not about shipping products, but
and so we need to get there.
Second stage is structured vibes. It's
all about balance and sustainability.
Like how do you bring maintain
maintainability,
more readable code, like things you
might actually somebody in the end might
want to read that code and you'll have a
handover to somebody else.
And you want to have some quality
control that what you build
is maintainable and not just a throwaway
project.
And lastly, we get to spectrum vibes.
And if you have done anything on Reddit
or on blocks in the in the past then you
past few weeks, you've probably seen
people sharing their kind of best
practices. This is how I finally got
good value out of AI and those are those
best practices are emerging, but they
bring you that scale, reliability, and
velocity that that comes with that while
still hopefully giving you some speed
and gratification along the way. But
reducing that chaos. Well,
maybe keeping the fun.
So vibe coding initially where we see
this outcome first. As I said, it's all
about not you don't even want to look at
the code. Like if you're in an editor
and I see actually people framing their
experience in AI editors of
low code mode. So they they just look at
the chat panel and look at whatever
comes out of it and that's the outcome
first.
It's all about natural language. It's
all about just staying in the flow and
doing working with the AI.
And it's what auto accepting changes. So
until it maybe no longer works, we might
want to undo, but otherwise we just keep
talking to the AI. I know you did this
wrong, try again.
Um
fix it or go to jail is a very popular
one. So you can do try all kind of, but
stay in natural language. Don't don't be
too specific.
So there is a use case for that though.
You want to
get a sense for YOLO vibe coding for
rapid prototyping, for proof of concepts
where you just want to get some here.
That's where I actually have a ton of
conversations with larger companies who
want to who start a conversation like,
"How can we do Vibe coding?" And for
them it's all about getting people who
are non-technical to be able to
communicate ideas. It's about UX people
just making a mock-up and being able to
bring that to meeting and being able to
communicate what they want to do in the
mock-up.
It's all about learning. Like I had we
had
last
uh 2 weeks ago at Build we had 1 hour of
Vibe coding on stage live and people
built games and I used 3.js which I have
tried many years ago but I haven't used
3.js in a while. But once I got the code
running, I could start getting into the
code and structured, how does it make
shapes and I could actually understand
technology because I have something
working.
And that's that's really the power of
getting something up and running that
that gives you that technology something
to hands-on to actually try out.
And of course personal projects. So um
I'm not sure how many of you had sit sit
down with somebody who's non-technical
and show them Vibe coding and just build
a what your water tracking app or you
build something with your kids. There's
all kind of personal projects you can
now finally solve over the weekend
thanks to Yolo Vibe coding.
So let's do some Yolo Vibe coding. This
is uh AI generated so I did
images do reflect the vibe. So this is
really about voice input
relaxing. I guess coffee is in there as
well, but
let's get it going.
Um
Okay.
So in VS Code for Yolo Vibe coding we're
going to start with an empty VS Code. So
hit command shift N. Sorry. Are we
supposed to use the insiders of VS Code?
I might show off insider stuff, but all
of what I'm showing is also in stable.
If you have insiders, use insiders.
Insiders is the pre-release version of
VS Code that ships on a daily basis,
like Firefox Nightly,
Chrome Canary Dev,
ships nightly.
So, on your left side, you will have no
folder open.
On your right side, you will have
Copilot open. Everybody got this?
Raise your hand.
Cool. Awesome.
So,
um
Who has used agent mode? Just checking.
So, I not have to explain everything.
Okay. Cool. So, agent mode, the probably
the default you want to have set and
default with setting.
Um Copilot 4 is great at front-end
stuff, so for me personally, my my
favorite. Is it big enough? Yeah.
And now, what's interesting, so just one
one quick tour of how we're going to do
vibe coding is there's actually this
interesting setting here. Is this
zooming? Yeah. Is new workspace in VS
Code.
And for this first round of vibe coding,
I want you to go into this tools picker
down here and actually disable scaffold
new workspace.
Cuz it will help you scaffold your
workspace, but it will
lower the vibes if you're just trying to
do HTML
coolness.
Oh, yes. Tools picker down here.
That's the little one.
Uh how to get into this menu? There's a
tool this tools picker.
Okay.
Uh-oh.
Yes, it might be in a different it was
in a different spot before. If you don't
see it, check that you're in agent mode.
Otherwise, you don't have tools.
Yes, ask my Yeah, okay. First step,
enter panel and switch to agent mode
down here.
It should might be in ask by default.
Yeah, it is. Cool.
And then second step, go into
the tools menu, which only appears in H
mode.
Soon, agent mode's going to be default,
and this whole where is my my tools
picker is
less of a problem.
Okay, so and then what you want to
uncheck is this new section.
And we're going to check out new
Yes. Do you see nothing? And I see those
two items and nothing else.
That's not enough. I I see more more of
you see um
You might be
Yes, I think that's fine. Let me just
Shoot.
Okay, you're good on your side.
Yes, I I think this is actually it's
very recent and we're actively working
on that. So, keep it keep it checked.
It's fine. So, let let's actually use
it. Um let's start with our first vibe
coding using new because it's so hard to
disable.
And the way we're going to do this is um
create a uh let's do React Vite. And
that's first lesson for vibe coding, use
stacks that are kind of popular in front
end where the AI doesn't have to reason
too much and make wild guesses. So,
React and Vite are good ways to run a
project.
Um website
that
for
What do we do?
Um
hydration tracking.
Water hydration
water consumption app.
Simple
and big accessible UI
following
uh What do we tell the AI to make it
really beautiful? We tell it I like to
tell it Apple
design principles.
You can infuse it with whatever design
sense you have. Mine is just make it
look pretty.
Which always helps
adding that extra. So, Vite water
tracking hydration
And that's what I see. So, we don't give
it any constraints. We don't tell it how
many buttons, like is it mobile
friendly, is it not mobile friendly, is
it um
what CSS language to use.
Uh I might actually not do React light,
but might Oh, yeah. Let's do that with
material language with material
material design.
So, yeah. Now, we got the stack. We got
a design direction and we tell told it
to make it pretty.
Okay.
And then hit run.
So, we're now in in a no folder state.
So, what's first happening is going to
tell us to empty to open an empty
folder. Everybody got that?
And they're flowing. Okay.
Going to hit continue. Now, it's going
to actually ask me to open a folder. I'm
going to make a new folder.
Vibing at
N A I engineering.
Put it anywhere.
Where you put your stuff.
Where you put your code. And now, it's
actually opening a new folder and it's
going to continue the setup.
And to explain a bit what's happening
here. So, this is using the new command.
A new command is is optimized for
creating projects from scratch, which
if you look at the internet of how
people evaluate
AI coding tools is what every second
person does. Can it make me a water
tracking app? Can it make me a movie
database app? And so, we optimize for
this flow, but also it makes for this
nice vibe coding from scratch because
everybody struggles with what is the
right stack, how do I get started, and
this is what this is here for.
Uh we got the latest. So, we got we can
now review the commands.
And this is maybe where we do the first
tweak of our settings.
So, if you go into settings and search
for approve,
you will find the auto approve.
And that's the first rule of vibe
coding. As we said, we we don't want to
look at code.
And we just want to have the AI do
stuff. So,
what you can do in my my case, I'm going
to actually go to over to workspace from
user to workspace. And that means that
setting is only set for this workspace,
which is the safest way to use this
setting. So,
use with caution. I'm going to auto
approve, which means all of these
continue buttons won't happen anymore.
And we just going to get results.
So, check that box, close it again.
And we can hit continue here.
This is using Vipe. This is fine. Now
now we're going to stop worrying about
the code. Uh but I can still read the
plan. So, install Material UI
dependencies, create hydration tracking,
Apple-inspired design, and project
structure.
So, it's running commands.
Um
Why is there files already in here?
Okay. Cool.
Skips.
What did it create? Oh.
Where did this music come from?
I guess it already did something. Cool.
Okay, we're on Yes, keep going.
This case, it tried to create something
and then it ran
another terminal command.
Keep going. That's fine.
Is it doing stuff for you? Do you see
things popping up?
Where is the
I can't find the folder.
Oh, did I approve? It It doesn't look
like it's in there.
You got to try it inside your settings.
Inside inside your settings. I'm not
using an insider, so I guess I should
be. Oh, wait. Did we That wasn't the
last version? Well, it's an insider. I
have an insider, I just haven't switched
back yet. Okay. Okay. Well, I can't find
it either.
Okay. It wasn't in non-insiders, though.
Was it?
Let me Let me check in VS Code stable.
Is it here or wait, not here? Uh
show settings cut.
Yeah, that's my my problem of not being
enough in stable.
I shouldn't run workshops.
There you go.
Wait.
Why is it different than looking for
Jesus?
So, you found it in
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
inside? Thank you so much.
There's two ways to get to the same
thing, but it's a different menu.
But, it looks the same. Oh, it's just
Anyway. Yeah. The settings? There's
settings from the bottom and settings
from the top, and they're not the same.
Oh.
Okay. I'm happy to go figure that out
later.
There's settings up here. The one The
one on the I used the gear I used the
gear setting from the bottom. Yeah. It
didn't work, but anyway. The settings
from the top. He he got the top bar. If
you hit Okay. Where's the other one?
Like the one on the
Oh, in
the other setting, yeah.
Yeah, I have customized my UI too much
as well.
Go. Good question.
So, if we
for this to run
I know it it keeps telling me to run
this in native terminal.
But, like the cursor
it gives you the it gives you the actual
error message.
Yes, that's that's why we I think I
should have said auto approve before, so
it's active for the chess session. But,
this is the setting I just showed is the
is the auto approve. So, you all the
continue buttons are basically gone.
And it just auto approves.
Yeah. Yeah.
And for MCP tools, we actually do have
drop-downs to allow
always allow for session and always
allow for workspace and or not always
allow. So, there's some more
fine-grained things we're rolling out to
more tools.
But, for Yep. It's still prompting to
continue when it is Yeah, I think it's
the auto proof is not applied to the
current session. That's
I showed it too late. Should have done
it the other way around.
Okay, we got some material design coming
in.
And this is where you need to get your
coffee and just wait.
Ooh.
That's a good idea. Sit down. Okay, open
your window.
Um okay, what what prompt did we use?
Create a right. So okay, now do in the
new window going to do auto proof first.
Um a
approve
Auto proof is already on. That's good.
Um
this is another window now. And we're
going to do the same thing. We're
actually going to use material design. I
guess And is still out there, right? And
or fluid fluent. That's the Microsoft
one.
Let's see what this looks like.
Again, it's going to prompt me for
folder.
Um Vibe being
at
AIE
two.
And this is I think one of the key
takeaways like trying out different
ways to get to the same result is where
Vibe coding really shines.
Is continue.
It's just trying I I had really good
success of just like what different
sign-up flows that we can create. Like
create three different versions of this
design to explore what this could look
like.
Okay, it installed.
It's up there in the next in the in the
one script. And that's where it gets
confusing if you have multiple open now
at the same time. You got to figure out
what's running what. And now this flow
actually over here runs without any
confirmation. So we we set auto proof in
the correct order.
And it's now just
creating Vibe, installing installing
fluent.
You notice that I got the wrong fluent
because it is a dependency.
Now it's fixing those.
Yes.
So the way I I do it command comma is a
quick way.
So I don't use menus. I should use
menus.
Um so you go up here. I have my settings
up here. Most probably have them on the
other lower side.
And you go in here and go into settings.
And this is what it should look like.
Do your settings look like this?
And then if you look for approve
Sorry. Can't type. auto approve
Do you see it?
It might be insiders.
It's all blur.
We're shipping on a monthly basis and I
thought we tweeted about it at the end
of last month. So
So you found it?
Okay.
Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. The good thing the person who owns
the AI terminal integration just came
back from paternity leave. So we're back
on the game working on it.
But the um there is definitely
we've been looking at how to allow
specific terminal commands and that's
how most tools do it. But if you think
about the scary parts of chaining and
running multiple commands in one
command. So terminals are not as
predictive as you would think and how
you can easily allow list things. So if
you mostly think about the how to do it
right, right?
Okay, now we got two vibe coding
sessions going on here. I have this one.
This is uh this is for tomorrow.
This is vibing is happening.
So what you see it it creates an app
TSX, it creates an app CSS. It also
creates copilot instructions.
Uh who's been using copilot instructions
before?
Yeah, so that's that's one way this
out-of-the-box experience just
does things for you. It comes with
instructions baked in which is nice. It
understands which stack you're using.
That's mostly about it. It already
captured my design principles that I
eloquently put in please make it look
like Apple.
And now it's actually there's a clean
minimal intuitive interface, consistent
UI, and everything else.
Uh it broke down the technical stack
even things I haven't mentioned like CSS
and responsive design. So it calls out
some of the assumptions that AI will
fill in if you give it a high-level
task.
Okay, this is still working on the index
CSS and
the other one is working on
the HTML file.
Yeah.
It will just do it for you. It will
usually do it as it
creates the project. I haven't typed
anything else so far and we're just
we're just vibing.
It um here created one.
Let me see if it created one both.
Okay, there we go.
Our first app is done.
Hydration tracker is stay healthy, stay
hydrated. Today's progress, we want to
quick add 500 ml
and it went with metrics. Isn't that
beautiful?
Just how I wanted it. Maybe it got my
accent, I don't know.
Um you can do plus minus. It's
interesting how mine is different. Yeah,
I know. I know.
So, does does everybody looks as nice as
mine?
Do you already see yours? Okay.
Yeah. Yours better?
Yeah.
Yeah. That's a
That's like a very wide open live coding
workshop. Um I ran these a few times and
this is probably one of the nicer ones.
So,
um but it's also I like actually running
these with different models and you're
getting a sense of how good each model
is at design and having design sense
without me telling it how to do
everything.
And Claude is definitely
usually rocking the the icons. It got
the colors really nicely.
So, uh that's looking great. This is a
really nice app. So, now next on because
of visual, like we haven't even checked
the code. We haven't read the CSS. We
haven't looked at the TSX. Like is it
still doing what it's doing functional
programming? Like how does it handle
state? I I don't I don't care. It works.
So, now you can actually do
a new feature we landed.
You can now say
work visually. So, I can now say this
header up here, I don't know what it's
called, like whatever progress
indicator.
Um
let's make this
uh more animated.
Adding
particles, maybe?
That's good. So, muy pet paper. So, this
is all
material design. This is material
design. Yeah. What did copy the
component name? I didn't. I hit start
down here. Uh if you have the browser
preview open, did it open for y'all?
Cool.
So, this is um
to point out two features. So, one
is in this flow at some point, it
basically started the task.
It's did npm run dev.
And then the next step I did, it opens
simple browser. And simple browser is
this VS Code in-browser preview we have.
And it will just um and what we're
injecting here, what just went away, is
a little toggle you can now use to
select specific elements that we then
attach as a visual reference reference
and a CSS into the current chat.
So, if I scroll back down,
here, I see what's being attached. I
actually actually click it. So,
everything you see under message is in
the context. The element screenshot
somehow didn't didn't make it through.
Uh but this one made it in, and that's
basically the CSS description and HTML
of the element we attached. So, I didn't
have to describe the element where it
sits.
It just did it for me.
Okay.
Ran into snacks. We don't care about
that. Let's check the other one. Ooh.
Number two, Fluent Design.
Uh this is what it came up with.
It's a little bit plain.
Um that's just sad.
Okay.
At least it had a goal reach, that's
nice. Um and it has recent entries. So,
it made similar assumptions
on what we want. So, feature-wise, it
somehow got to the same conclusion, but
design-wise,
uh this is definitely more corporate.
Um yeah. So, that's
the simplicity of live coding and
using the new tool out of the box. Uh if
you are an insider, you can disable new
tool, it's easier to do like a single
file HTML thing cuz new tool is
definitely biased towards using
NPM and installing packages. So it
always ends up a little bit more
um
complex.
Do you work with Do you work with
insiders team?
Yes. Precisely. The team I work on. So I
Hi, I'm Harold. I work on VS Code.
Yeah. It'd be really cool to understand
when you open up your new insiders
what are the new things that just came
Like like a like a quick GIF somehow.
Like someone could show me like Yeah. I
have them both on my machine. Right. And
I use them both.
But then I like fall behind a couple
days back. It's like, "What are the new
things and why I should be using
insiders?" Like what's Yes. So the the
best way to stay on top of what's new is
we we do actually right now this week
it's testing week and we're writing our
release notes. So the release notes are
usually capturing everything that's new,
but for insiders it's hard because it's
coming out every day. So it's hard to
just
point.
That's a great idea. We're going to make
an MCP server that summarizes what
landed. Yeah. Yes, I like that. I like
that. I like that.
Let's let's do it for the next next
demo.
Next demo.
Okay. So what do we have in our Yolo
vibing toolbox? We have the agent
um which sometimes is hard to find. Now
you're all on the agent, so that's
great.
It's all about um
Actually didn't show that.
I could have shown that. It's
different panel styles. So if I go back
here, um you can actually move this into
the editor.
Which is nice. So some people like that.
More space for your chat. Um
you can also
if I go back into my panel
Oh, I moved in in into the drop down
here.
And you can move your chats into here.
So you can have multiple chats and they
actually have names. So it's easy to go
back and forth. You can put them in
parallel to your code so you can use all
the like window management things.
run them in separate windows?
Yes. Wait.
How did you know?
Um
Okay, where do we go? In new window.
There you go.
Now you have a chat
in its own window. You can put it on
your own monitor. So, future can
succeed. And you can actually pin it on
to be top. So, now if I run this and I
can close
this.
Uh oh.
Let's move that away first so I can
accept this. This you're all going to
keep.
Uh close it.
And then close the other one.
And now we have the output and we can
just move our chat across and fully
focus on the exponentials
that are happening in this window.
Yeah. So, that's one way you can really
manage
the space how you want it.
Uh new workspace flow we showed.
So, it's really this optimized
CLI first. Good question.
Okay, okay. Yeah, and then voice
dictation I haven't shown. Uh who has
tried voice dictation in GitHub Copilot
already?
Okay, magic moment of
um
Add a dark mode, please, and maybe
give it a cool name that works
with a younger audience who needs to
drink more or maybe my kids. Make it for
kids.
So, a little more kid-friendly.
Thank you.
Bye.
Okay, so um
command I is actually default shortcut.
Um it's it's a local model, which is
great for
privacy and it's really fast. Uh it's
accurate um
There's some option as well if you when
you use command voice input that it also
reads back the text, which is great for
accessibility.
And yeah, by using just your voice, you
can now finally now put that coffee down
and just keep keep vibing.
Uh there's a hey co-pilot as well. I
think we did at some point, which I
haven't used in a while.
Okay.
Uh
I said all that. Keyboard shortcuts
There's a keyboard shortcut you want to
customize it to actually hold down while
you talk and then let go.
Uh visual context I showed attaching
It's great for wireframes. The inner
preview gets hot reload. It just works.
And you can attach the elements using
that little send button.
And then auto accept I showed the auto
proof tool. There's also an auto uh tool
auto proof
tool setting.
Uh there's also an auto accept after
delay. If you don't have that on, I love
auto save.
It's a great VS Code feature that's
already working uh um basically after
delay or after focus change,
it will just save it for you.
And what I haven't showed, let's see if
this this works here,
is the undo button.
Is this still going? What's What's this
one doing? I forgot.
Um
Oh, this is adding the particles. Cool.
It's still worked on that. Good
co-pilot.
Okay. Get stunning animations. That's
great. That's what I wanted.
Is it doing it now?
So, let's keep
Huh! It does animate. Nice.
Particle No, I look at bubbles.
Okay.
Um I don't like it. Undo. Up here. Uh
those are basically our our checkpoints.
Uh there's a new checkpoint UX coming,
but because I have many people saying
tell me, "Oh, you don't have
checkpoints. I can't undo stuff." But if
you already accepted stuff or if you
want to go back to something like this
is
I like these particles but for for V0.
Oh, that was beautiful. I love it.
Uh we don't need that, then you can also
bring that back. Just need to see that
again.
That's really nice.
Okay. So,
for people who don't like particles, we
can now undo
and it's now back to the original
version. So, it it has stages for each
of the
of the work it did and you can easily go
back and forth to see the before and
after as well.
Yeah.
But in Vibe code, you don't want to look
at the code because
we don't look at the output.
Okay. Um, that's
the Yolo toolbox.
And I think as I mentioned before, you
want to try it out just to get into the
AI. Like in my case, I mentioned I like
getting a sense of how good AI is at
design. Like can I just give it wide
tasks to explore space and it'll like
come up with something interesting or do
you need to how detailed do I need do I
need to be? When does it make mistakes?
If I give it a general task maybe about
Java where it's not as good at, like
what will it do?
Um, next one is known frameworks. We
went with Vibe, Material Design, things
that are kind of off-the-shelf and
haven't changed in a long time uh
in a large scale.
So, you want to use something that's
popular and have has been consistent.
And lastly, we do use it as a
whiteboard. Um, we showed just attaching
a visual element, change this, add some
particles.
Um, it's really about not being becoming
too attached with whatever you're
working on but being um
able and willing to throw it out and
start from scratch if things go wrong.
Structured Vibe coding is this middle
stage tries to balance the Yolo, the fun
and chaos with a more structured
approach.
And there it's um I think it's the
biggest impact I see from
talking to customers on like this is
this is how Vibe coding can work for us.
This is where we can bring somebody
non-technical in,
give them a good starter template that
has a consistent tech stack
that comes with clear instructions for
the LM and how to work on it and keeps
it in its actual guardrails.
And already brings in some custom tools
that bring in expert domain knowledge or
internal knowledge that you would need
to work on this codebase.
And that's really kind of Yolo on on
guardrails. It's faster and gives you
more consistent results. So you don't
end up with something oh it used
material design but it should have used
fluent or it used should have added dark
mode and should have been responsive.
All of that can already be baked into
the instructions.
So I see a lot of companies bring that
into their bootstrapping for greenfield
projects. So we have something and you
can oftentimes is you go into meeting
and you have a product that looks
already finished because you vibe coded
it with your go-to stack and uses your
internal design system. So it already
looks way more polished.
And the last piece I think out of
mainstream workloads is where Yolo by
default will always bias towards
whatever is top of the training stack.
With this one you can then customize it
further down to internal stacks,
internal workloads, internal deployment
infrastructure
that makes it work better.
So let's do structured vibe coding. This
is now the image as I I explained is now
has wireframes and uh more charts. So
that's what makes it more structured.
There we go. Let's open.
So what I'm going to do now I think I'm
going to push this.
Ops this is still running.
Let's see if this works. I did
create this vibe coding. So I do have
another one that I can share.
Just look at this one and I'm going to
push it
to GitHub.
This comes free with me, fine. Um cool,
front end vibes. Perfect.
Um
This is all vibes, so we're going to
make this live. Um this is commit.
And then
Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah, this is one.
Who has been using this commit button
here?
So, Copilot will write your commit
message.
Done. This looks good. And now sync
changes.
And I'll share the repository.
This repository might still be an old
name. Let me see.
Yeah, probably. Let me just
check where it sits.
Cuz I forgot where it sits.
Oh, it's perfect. Sleep vibes.
This is one of my vibe exercise. Okay,
this
For browser window?
Which?
The
Oh, yes, yes. Um
yes, the simple browser.
So, we're going to
simple browser show. That's it.
Okay, the repo we're pulling down is
Whoop. Whoa, whoa, whoa.
This one.
Sleep vibes.
Doesn't have a dev container, but it's
only node Node.js, though. So, it
shouldn't be
too gnarly.
Do we want to get the agent to use some
special magic to pull this or should we
just
Should I try it?
It's a It's a good clone.
You can ask the agent to get clone it
for you, yes.
I'm just curious if there's some special
tool that would be more than that.
Just the user
Oh, sorry.
Digital old, that's me.
Yes.
Okay, and then npm install on it and
then
Yeah.
If we would have prepared better, it
would have been a code space and a dev
container and you just click open in
code spaces and things work. Um
Come to my next show and then we'll get
that fixed.
You got it.
Yeah.
Let me actually just open the code space
to see.
Now I'm curious if it just works.
Anybody's been using code spaces
on GitHub?
How many? Okay, occasionally.
The complexity lies in all the different
versions of the feature parity between
insiders, the regular version, all of
the plugins, and some of them don't work
and
Oh, the bug, yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
If everything just worked the same, it
would be
Yes. It mostly does, right? But mostly,
right?
it's 95% there. Yeah. But it's the 5%
where once something doesn't work, you
just go back to the other tool. Yeah.
So, VS Code now that I have the code is
offering me to reopen it in a container.
So, if it does a container configuration
You can try. I haven't I have seen it
running in a container, but if you want
to
The container is just a Node.js one.
And it should work, too.
I did add a container. See?
I live coded my container, too.
Wait, I I can now check. So, if you ever
wonder what what you did on a project,
um
So, this is where I created my
container. This is where I just asked
uh GitHub Copilot to update my dev
container. Just look at my code base and
update my dev container. So, it did a
good job here.
Should have maybe
remembered that I did that, as well.
Okay, if if you're ready What meanwhile,
while you clone, while you npm install,
anybody got it working already?
Still cloning. Okay. Cool. I'll give it
the tour
of what we have. So, one is we again
start with good
Copilot instructions.
And they live in
.github/copilot-instructions.md.
It's a markdown file that's included
with all your agent requests, all your
chat requests, all your inline chat
requests. It just Copilot basically
gives it grounding, foundation knowledge
about your code base.
And sometimes they feel a bit
repetitive, like um
20 I I saw some demos of like use
basically repeats linting rules that you
expect AI to just follow anyways.
But I I like
um my go-to is just a one-liner on what
what what's your stack. That's that's a
good starting point. Just point it to
what frameworks,
what version,
and that's one way to just keep it on
rails with what what it uses.
That's it.
I was experimenting with this, figuring
out what would be the best way to
have that be a standard that gets
included in.
But like let people
not not mess with that. Like give people
some coding structure. Yeah. If you have
a whole team of five coders, but
you probably don't want them touching
that.
So this is in your repo. So I think it's
a good team exercise to iterate on it.
Like it shouldn't be a stale document.
You can put this in your user settings
as well. You probably don't want it with
each app. You probably want it as a
different repo, right? You could do
that, yeah.
a way that you code and then each app
codes. I've been thinking about that,
too.
Yes.
So I've been trying to convince on my
peers on a GitHub site this should be an
organizational setting that people can
accept easily on a like a organizational
level and like something as a as a team
you can select which ones you want to
use. So we're working on that this
discovery.
Sure.
always one file or can you opt in for
like cuz if you have different
languages, different
Good question.
Yeah. So we have this one now. This
These are new instructions. So they This
These are These become rather monolith
than large and unwieldy.
And now
uh just went out here before I go to new
ones. I do also guide which tools to
use. I do have my first MCPs in here and
I already tell it for front end Q&A
review use the browser tools that come
from Playwright. Research I use
Perplexity. I have uh Context Seven in
here which has library docs and it keeps
using this ID tool to look up IDs, but I
just gave it these are the IDs you
should use. Don't don't use the other
tool.
So there's ways you can already guide it
to specific tools you want it to apply
when needed.
Um the rest is just syntax formatting
optimizations. Um
key conventions. Yeah. And then the
other format we have is
.github/instructions/name.instructions.md.
And those have this front matter syntax
that's becoming more popular for rules
of
what what files it should apply to. So
they start to be scoped with a glob
pattern. And then right now they're
limited to being applied. You actually
have to have the file in context. So a
TypeScript file would only be applied if
I actually do have a TypeScript file
in here.
Or I do have one open and then I enable
this context and then it would be
applied. But if I only have this
right now, which means this isn't
included, it wouldn't actually apply the
rule. We're we're fixing that and it's
going to be more
working as expected, probably. Um
but that's that's right now.
That's like the biggest question I get.
Like it didn't include my rule because
right now it really wants to see that
file.
Um
yeah, so those those are new. Uh those
shipped in the last version, so they
should be also in stable and we're
actively working on those. So and then
the the new new thing is plans or
prompts.
And then we have the first
kind of reusable tasks for as a team,
how do you think about
engraining like oh, we now have finally
way
to tell GitHub Copilot to write tests.
And your AI champion in the team
handcrafts this perfect prompt which
one-shots your tests
consistently. And now everybody's shared
it in Slack, copies it around. Once you
want to write tests, you go back to
Slack, copy it back. And that's what you
want to use prompts for. You can finally
put these prompts into a place where
they can just be used by everybody. And
how can they be used? So I showed these
can actually be be attached, so you can
also
go in here
and attach instructions, so you can you
can do it manually, too. So, that's one
way. But, I can also now go in here. I'm
in the chat window and hit slash.
And I can now actually
run user prompts that are my own, that I
create for myself, and I can use my plan
and spec
prompt you see over here on the left.
Can you make up a custom
Yes. These are custom. So, the ones I
have here, these are already
custom in the workspace.
And then the other ones
I don't have I'm not showing, so
I think we do. Wait, there's a new menu.
make up a ridiculous name for the
answer?
Yes. Yeah, yeah.
You can name it for you. So, let's make
it here. Um
So, this this one actually just landed
yesterday because insiders
we can now finally have an entry point
because everybody kept asking, "How do I
create prompts?" And I have to tell them
which command to find it in.
So, this is the new prompt
configuration file, and I have some
already here. So, as you mentioned, like
this is one that's interesting for
um
If I open this one, this is like
defining how I want to write custom
instructions. So, whenever I'm in a new
project that doesn't have custom
instructions yet, I do run this prompt
to to bootstrap them for me.
And yes, there should be a prompt
sharing website where you can find these
amazing prompts that I create and
next week, we're going to
So, each prompt is like a separate
It's like
separate in each other. Yes. So, that's
the main difference between
instructions. Instructions are you can
have multiple. If you work on, for
example, if you have one for TypeScript
and one for your front-end folder, they
do combine because there's multiple
instructions that hopefully don't
conflict with each other.
Um but they they allow you to be
attaching multiple instructions, and
they're really more about code, whereas
prompts are basically uh easy ways to
inject something in this prompt field
and they stay in the conversation,
but they
um they're mostly around a task and
maybe giving the AI something like
specific to do. Instructions you
wouldn't necessarily give it like what
to do, but more how to do it.
What about if you wanted to print the
table?
Keep it to
um
always do TDD when it's writing code.
That Yeah. Yeah, so TDD um good point.
Uh that would be a good way to use
custom modes. So, if we go into here,
custom uh sorry. So, this is only
Insiders cuz it just landed. So, you
can't follow along or if you're not
Insiders.
So, custom modes will show up
um in the drop-down. So, this is I going
to Now, it just went into the menu,
created a custom mode, and now I can
pick where it shows up. So, it's got
github/chatmodes, which put it into the
repository,
or I just want to keep it for myself.
So, a good pattern if you just want to
experiment, put it in your user folder.
If you want to
make everybody's life better in your
team and you have high confidence that
your mode does that, then you put it
into the project.
And then uh we're going to do name this
one TDD.
And then we're going to
ask AI to fill it in, write uh prompt.
Um expert expert prompt uh for Wait, I
was just typing.
Wait.
Hi there, AI. We need a prompt that
enforces test-driven development
uh for GitHub Copilot. So, it should
probably first make sure it understands
the problem, then write tests first, and
only after tests are done, maybe get
confirmation from the user
to then write the implementation
and then keep running the tests against
implementation. Cool. Thanks.
It's important.
I did not I didn't say actually I'm not
worried because I didn't actually
activate my files context. Let's see if
it
I think it should have a tool to just
create more it's for you've asked it.
So, it's going to going to make that an
MCP server next.
Okay. Oh, it got it. Okay, wonderful.
So, we have a test driven development
assistance. It's This is by code we
don't want to repeat the code. Test
development assistant core principles
understand
red. Write failing tests first.
Beautiful. I would have not green. Wow,
it does follow.
Refactor improve code quality strict
rules no mutation of the tests.
Beautiful. Beautiful. So, this our new
TDD mode.
Um
We've done it four.
Looks pretty good. It has emojis.
Example. Should we try it out?
Okay, we have
Um
These are framework. It's framework
independent looks like.
Oh, just yeah, I think it does yeah.
It does make some stuff up. Yeah,
wouldn't need to do that.
I can take this out.
I already have my So,
Um
Cool. Test drive the design. Wonderful.
Okay, let's do it. So, we have this
project which doesn't do anything. If
you just run this,
um
NPM run dev probably doesn't
I think I already did this before. So,
this is just a basic plain landing page.
So, let's do the um
What feature do we have?
I want a dashboard for GitHub users.
Just use mock data because I don't want
to wire it up to GitHub. So, want to
have maybe some interesting contribution
metrics.
And
But first, actually, let's make a plan.
Meanwhile, while I type this in, let's
stop it. Um
TDD.
So, a dashboard for GitHub.
Um Don't wire it up.
So, now again, we give it a very broad
task, but we can now put it into
TDD mode.
Which is our new amazing
test and development mode that follows
all the best practices. I assume that
the AI knows about TDD.
And let's see.
So, you Wait, that's a You created a new
mode there. Yeah.
Because So, we went previously went into
configure chat modes. We created a new
mode. This mode is now enforcing the
technique. We can actually in a mode,
you can say which tools it's supposed to
use. So, Is the mode that that's kind of
confusing me. You use the mode
in agent mode, but based on the other
markdown file. So, it's a It's a custom
agent mode.
Yes. Yeah. When is that going to be
live?
Uh it's an Insiders now. It's So, it's
going to ship next week on on the 11th.
Yeah. How often does Insiders ship?
Insiders ships daily, but it only
releases monthly.
Yeah. And we're one one week late uh
because there was a short short week, so
we adjusted our schedule.
Yes. Um so,
for most of you, this menu it just have
these entries
and the in insiders only
if you look for modes in the command
palette. So, command palette you can
also click up here show run commands
and then modes and that's that's the
place.
Yeah.
Yeah. Are they in in the output or in
the problems view?
Okay. Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
It
if it runs the commands itself, it will
start looking at the terminal. So, the
easiest way if you if you run the
deployment and the scripts itself
through copilot itself. But otherwise,
there's also context actually if you
look
here we have um
the
It is actually
terminal last there's terminal last
command which includes the output as
well in terms selection.
Now, if you ask me why they're not in
the add context, like I couldn't tell
you right now.
Yeah.
But yeah, that's working. I think I did
this thing wrong though. TDD,
let's just see.
Oh, the tools. It configured it made up
tools. So, it did that's that's a part
it
made up. There's actually those are not
the right tools.
Um
this is why it didn't do anything. It
was when I It just basically acted like
chat and gave me the code.
Cuz all the tools it tried were
uh it didn't have any right access.
So, let's try this again.
So, this is probably a good good good
point to good thing to point out. So, in
now prompts as well,
let me open plan prompt. So, this one
can actually now set tools.
And if you just make it tools into here
to tools,
you can now actually click here and say
which tools. In this case, this is a
planning to prompt. So, I'm mostly you
probably wanted it to look at
Perplexity
to come up with anything it needs to
find on the internet.
Uh I can select that. So, that's the way
you can now
have
tools
constrained for specific prompt.
Which which always helps with higher
kind of higher quality because if you
have many tools, which as you install
more MC P servers, you always I have
this tooling explosion and they might
have solved all different problems
you're having throughout the day,
but now you can configure it more
specifically for domain.
And
also insiders only, we have
tool
groups uh tool sets actually call them.
So, tool sets, I can
How do I get here? Um
down here
in the tool drop down, configure tool
sets, and add more tools. This I think
sends you to add server. But configure
tool sets, open this.
Opens this one here, and that's only for
Anything. Both built-in and MCP.
Actually, a lot of the tools you see
here, we cleaned this list up.
If you use Insiders, you see them.
Then these are actually tool sets
already. So, you use tool sets
internally because edit files has
multiple ways to edit files. We give the
AI a few ways.
Uh code base search has grep, has file
search, has different searches as well,
depending on what you're looking for.
So, all of these actually are tool sets
in our own back end, and we expose this
now as something you can create
yourself. So, my research tool, for
example, has the Perplexity tool
to ask deep research questions, and it
also has fetch.
No, I didn't. No, we can show.
Yes, again.
Wouldn't be a talk without MCP. This is
Also, there's a talk tomorrow about MCP.
A whole talk track.
Where I'll be talking about MCP, if I
can finish my slides.
Um okay, there we go. So, let's talk
about MCP. This is doing
something. Let's see. Not
I'm listening requirement. It create
mock data. Red phase writing tests. It
wrote tests.
It Oh, it found it as a no package
library. That's That's sad. Um
And it created the test utility.
And then it tried to run the tests.
Um and then it asked to proceed. So,
that's cool. So, it did the first stage
of that mode.
Um
We don't need to go too deep. But that's
mode TDD. It will ask now for
Cuz we asked it to ask actually for
confirmation. So, that's why it's now
pausing. It wrote tests. Uh they're all
red.
So, that's good.
Okay, we accepted, and let's go into
MCP. So, MCP servers Who has already MCP
servers set up in their VS code?
Good.
Two. Okay. Um
one way to get SP servers is editing
JSON. And there's really um there's few
other ways, but let me show you another
way. Um Playwright MCP, who's been using
Playwright MCP?
It's probably one of the the coolest
ones.
Um
So, Playwright MCP is a browser testing
framework and allows people to access
the browser locally and just take
screenshots, run websites, get
accessibility audits, a whole bunch of
utility in there.
And how to get it for VS code, there's a
JSON blob that you can all ignore and
just hit install server.
So, install server is a just a VS code
protocol that we use to just wire things
up into VS code. You see the same if you
go to the extensions marketplace for VS
code, you can hit install extension,
that powers the same process.
So, now I can insta um don't hit show
configuration. We need to move this
down, but install server actually puts
this now into my user settings.
And as you can see, you can have MCP
servers both for yourself.
And I have the one for GitHub and for
gist pad, which is a cool one. I can
recommend this one.
And then yeah, Playwright now.
So, you can already see
how many
um
tools it provided. You can see if
anything fails, you can get to the
output.
If
there would be configuration, I can show
that here.
There's actually gist pad needs a GitHub
token, so it's a local MCP.
And what
have you ever seen that one? So,
yay, no tokens in my configuration. So,
you can use inputs in VS code
configuration both in the MCP.json and
your settings. And inputs, you might
have already seen those in tasks or
JSONs how you configure your tests and
your build steps in VS code. It's the
same system.
They're defined up here. So, inputs are
just an ID, a type, description, a
default value, and the password true
means it's encrypted at rest
after you put it in. So, it doesn't ask
me anymore.
It would if it but this this shows
basically that it already has a token.
But if you enter it the first time
and we can actually try it if I
in VS code's key storage. So, if I'm on
Mac, it's actually uses keychain. Okay.
Yeah.
So.
What other MCP servers do
Yeah, so I can show um
Just by this one is done by actually
um
some of my GitHub's or justpad.dev
justpad MCP. That's mostly I'm going to
show it off tomorrow as well my talk.
Um but it's a fun one
that uses
uh just as a knowledge base
and also for prompts. So, I really like
this one.
Uh it adopts a ton of like recent MC MCP
stuff, but I think the main ones we
usually see is GitHub MCP server.
Just pad just
Lost in tangent. Yeah. So, this uh if
you just want to play around with a with
a really well-done MCP server, then
that's that's one.
Um not saying that the GitHub one isn't
as good,
but it's um
there's a lot more coming here as well.
So, they're all in like really active
development to figure out what the best
way for MCP is. Yeah.
Yeah.
Where how did you connect to the Let's
say I have a Python
Yeah.
Okay.
Just to see.
Yeah. Okay.
Okay, and you and
Right. And in your case that server is
already running. So, how how to hook up?
Okay, cool. Yeah, let's do that.
So, SSE
um same way basically is so what
just finding my
uh
make make it out. So, go back to my mcp.
json
and down here
Yes. So, to clarification mcp.json which
sits in .vscode right now and it's per
workspace and that's shared across
everybody. So, hopefully it puts up
either you work on it alone
and it's just for you or everybody is
happy to have those mcp servers.
Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah.
Okay, and then the what's now if you hit
at server you will find what you're
looking for.
And then from at server you can hit down
on HTTP. So, we actually do support both
SSE which is actually deprecated and
streamable HTTP which is
uh the the new fangled easier to scale
better for your cloud.
It's no longer in the spec, yes, and we
do fall back to it on the client side.
But it's it's the SSE is really hard on
on hosting, right? Because they have
these long running connections.
Long long poll, yeah. Yeah. So.
Yeah, so that's that's where you're
putting your yeah, mcp SSE server. And
if you want to do it manually it's
really just um
you get a nice auto complete, too. So,
if you pick a name
example and this would be
the type would be
not studio. Actually, it's HTTP. Yeah,
you already would you would use HTTP and
then it would already yell at you that
you don't have a URL. So, you're going
to put a URL.
So, this this is how
uh everything is by default as as studio
once you have your URL. I think I can
take this out. Yeah, so it would be
would be just that entry.
Yes, so to get Yes, um you see
many demos I see people hit start here
as well just to see that it's working.
It's a nice configuration that just make
sure it's working. We actually do cache
the tools once we saw them the first
time. So, how MCP works
is that on the first in a
initialization from the client to the
server, it shares its tools back and
that's what you see here, the one tool.
So, if you would do it right, you would
never know the tools unless you start
the server. We actually cache them so
you don't have to We don't have to start
all these servers proactively once you
open co-pilot just to get the tools.
Yes. Yeah.
No, actually you want to be in agent
mode. Agent mode ask mode will not run
MCPs for you.
Uh you can you can go
uh because ask mode is not it's not
actually there's no function calling
inherently, right? The ask mode is
really this traditional ask ChatGPT
question will answer based on its
training data or its context.
Um
Yes.
So, there is also an aspect you don't
have tools, you would see it. Um but I
can do actually Does this still work?
Um
Let's do that more quickly.
I think I should do this still.
Yes, so we're actually blurring line a
bit now. So, if you do
It's not working. Okay.
Yeah, but if you actually reference
specific tools in ask mode, it will
invoke them for you. But by default, the
the way where you want to execute tools
is in agent mode.
Yeah.
Uh they're all coming through GitHub
Copilot. So, they're all using your paid
uh you can add your own models. Anybody
has tried it?
Managing your models, so
Um so, I have Gemma 3 through Llama,
which runs locally, and I have open
routers Perplexity or one uh which is
actually a fine-tuned model from of Deep
Seek R1 from Perplexity.
So, if you haven't tried it yet, uh
basically go into the model picker and
hit manage models, and then we we can
actually custom configure your own API
keys from Anthropic, Azure, Cerebras,
Gemini, Grok. All of these um Llama's a
local one. So, if you have a beefy M4
Pro, I'm still sad how many models I can
actually run on this. But But
eventually, it's going to be small
powerful models um that makes sense.
So,
Uh it might be cuz of your anthropic
tier, right? That's
Um or is it
You have sign in for?
Oh oh the other one. Yeah, you might be
in agent mode.
So we do actually filter them down. So
that's an ongoing improvement we're
doing. That's why it's not It's right
now a preview feature only because we're
still having to correctly correctly wire
up which model allows tool calling.
So there's some some every provider has
different indicators of how tool calling
works and that's that's one of the
matching
things we're doing right now. So you
might not see it because it's not on our
our list yet.
Yes. Yeah, you you you you will see
that. So if I do just um
Well, one example here.
Uh
so just just so A, you can disable them.
If you want to If you want to be faster,
you can do command down
and just go through. So contact seven is
the one I want to keep. Player it I can
disable right now. But once you start
using them,
this is command up and down.
The power user way of navigating
those. So these are all built-in MCP
servers and once you start, you can
actually now if I want to be a very
explicit and I know which tools I want,
I can use my tool sets or I can mention
specific tools that are
um in in my list.
But I can also now just go in and say
what what do we want to do here? Um
research
uh
GitHub
metrics.
Let's actually use the research one cuz
we created it.
Sounds better when I use research here.
Use it in a sentence.
for productivity.
And now what happens now is uh this one
has now is an agent mode. We have the
research group set or tool set. So,
we'll either use Perplexity or Fetch.
And
one of my Perplexity keys actually
outdated cuz it failed before. Let's
see. Okay. So, you see I already
actually approved this before. So, you
see A
that it runs the server and actually
click the server to see where it comes
from.
Um if it would have if not auto auto
approved this because auto approve is
still on from our previous session.
You can actually go in here and edit
what it's sending.
Um which now doesn't make sense cuz it's
it's already sent.
And then it writes up uh what it found
in this case.
Does that underscore ask have anything
to do with fluidity?
Uh no, that's just the odd name for the
Perplexity tool. Okay.
It happens to coincide with Yes. Yeah,
yeah. It's just um
the verb should be before. So, it's
their their naming. Yeah.
Yeah. So, that's now run two. It
actually did a follow-up query as well.
And explained it. And now I could put
this in into a spec as well. It's
actually
I did this before. So, I wrote a spec
using for community dashboard. So, I did
the research using Perplexity. And then
ask it to write a spec from it using a
little query I have here for the spec.
Um
So, that's one way you can quickly get
things done.
And just to point out this one, it's a
pointing it to the spec. So, these are
actually resolved by the AI. So, if you
point it to spec files, we do actually
validate those as well. So, if you get
them wrong
I think they're in the lane. Um
you can also click them so you get all
the markdown
goodies. Um
and then you just ask it to write on the
spec, do nothing else. Uh use Perplexity
to look up stuff.
Don't lose details, keep updating the
spec. So, that's that's one way to work
on specs. Probably That's probably more
more tools we'll we're going to add
here.
Yeah, so that's MCP. Any other MCP
questions?
Uh
per MCP. So, the MCP itself doesn't run
anything
except when you support sampling
which we do
on Insiders.
Sneak preview for tomorrow. So, but
yeah, but if you use sampling, actually
I guess I have to explain sampling. So,
sampling is a way for MCP to reach back
out from the server to the client to use
the LLM on the client.
And it's you can often think the best
use case case are to summarize. Use
cases are if you want to
um reduce the amount of tokens you send
to the back to the client to explain
something.
So, there's a few ways, but um
overall, there's not enough integration
of sampling, um but so we're the first
ones to to get it out there because we
already have the LLM exposed.
So, that's cool.
Yeah.
To pick the model, kind of?
Right.
Right. So,
So,
Yeah.
So, what I recommend is A in in your
modes, boil down the tools to what you
actually need. So, reducing the tools
manually,
either deterministically already in in
your prompt, so this prompt could have
tools for like what it should actually
do, right? That would be one way.
Then I can configure what I actually
want to have here. Like this should be
only doing Perplexity because I it it
needs to do research, and that's all it
should do. With custom modes, that is
Yeah.
Custom mode, yeah.
been pockets of like code like this,
code like this, and Right. then you kind
of pick your pockets
Yes. So, custom mode is one way. And
then the other one is you can actually
mention specific tools. So, if we go in
here into add context,
and then you can actually point it to
specific tools. So, you're not doing
like the
look up things on GitHub, and you try to
find the right verbiage that it gets the
right tool. You can just actually
mention the tool of it should
um
for example, resolve library D. So, it's
you can just add these here, and then it
will be handed to the AI of like these
are the tools the user wants to use.
Can you select you see that you
deterministically select that tool or
not? It's it's still it Yeah.
Right.
No one like any of the models say here,
they don't care about tools.
End users work with the chatbot.
What tool it needs to use.
Yeah. It's still not deterministic.
Yes. Yeah, tool calling is inherently
always even in this case. We're telling
the AI you should use it, but it might
not use it. Yeah.
was like, yeah, this could be
determined. It's not.
Yeah.
So, my timer is down to zero. Maybe just
go back to the slides to wrap it up.
Yeah, more, right?
Um
live coding.
So, we showed workspace instructions. We
showed dynamic instructions which only
apply to parts of the tool set.
Uh we showed custom tools, and we'll
play right, deep research. Uh, I haven't
showed using web docs, like actually one
of my favorites. Just point it to an
existing repo and say read this repo if
you have questions. MCP works great for
that. When I work on MCP server, I just
tell it look in the TypeScript SDK
server for model context protocol if you
have questions. Because we have cross
repo search, it just works.
Um, the agent actually has access to
problems and tasks. So, if you have
tasks set up and you have linting set
up, things will just work. So, make sure
those are set up in your template.
Um, generic commits I showed, and then
fine-grained review. You can pause it
anytime. If it asks you questions, you
can always type something in and keep
steering it in the right direction.
And you can trust read-only in specific
tools. And I showed you also editing.
So,
yeah, instructions keep refining them as
it makes mistakes.
One of the key ones is commit often. I
didn't show commits now, but anytime you
got to have a working state, just make
sure you commit it so AI can continue
making mistakes and be creative.
And then last one, there's a clear pause
button in the lower end. So, if AI goes
off and you're like, what is it doing?
Like is it doing the right thing? Just
just pause and review. And that's
possible as well.
Uh, I showed a bunch of this for
spectrum development already, but it's
really about having a spec, having a
blatant done a plan, and doing more
custom prompts and tools, which I
showed.
Um,
show reason prompts.
Um, there's more MCPs for database
access and logging and project tracking,
like the GitHub MCP.
And there's also access to actually
tests and do debugging within the agent
as well. So, if you ask it to test in
development, like we did, it will
actually start running the tests if
they're set up in VS Code correctly.
And then we talked briefly about models
as well. So, if you want to use O3 for
any of the cool stuff, uh, the deeper
thinking, you can do that as well.
Um
spec driven is really about focusing on
the spec. And I think a great way to do
that is just create a spec from all the
conversations you had about the spec.
So, one way if you have a transcript
from a meeting about the project you
want to do, just feed that in and make
sure you call out what the final
decision is. It's a great way to have
meetings, but it's also a great way to
not write the spec yourself in the end.
Are there any tools to determine whether
spec is good or not?
Like on the opposite side of that, like
if you write the spec or a project
requirements document. Right.
Is like a
One of the one of the I would ask AI.
Yeah.
Twitter who really has something to say
about this. Says what he does is he has
it generate a spec and then he has it
critique the spec and say what are
things that it's missing and how can it
be better and stuff like that. And then
he basically argues with the LLM about
the spec until he gets the statement he
wants.
Yes. Arguing with AI is one good way.
So, if I I put some one run prompt or
prompt
is where is one critique idea is one I
like of just ask me three questions
about my idea, right? Just have AI go
into
thinking mode. Like what would you ask
somebody for feedback?
Um
and
have it critically analyze your stuff.
So, these prompts like the those are
basically the next level of prompt
crafting where you don't just ask it to
code, but
pull it in as a thought partner, as a
design partner, as somebody who can poke
um holes in your
I
deal along the way. So,
Yeah. Um further on review steps is
Yeah. Good.
Go ahead. Is there a plan mode? Is there
anything in a similar mode? A plan You
know can create one. So, we haven't done
have a plan mode built in, but we also
know ask edit agent will not be there
forever. So, it's a a series of
evolutions. Rue has way more modes that
you can customize.
So, I think we want to allow developers
to create their own.
Um because I even see very few demos of
people in client using plan. They just
give it a thing and then it runs, right?
Yeah.
It is yeah. Planning in in Vipe coding
you even do planning and then writing
the implementation plan. So, you would
have spent way more time on that initial
just
what and how we're doing things and then
you let it implement. So, that would be
even plan
write the implementation plan or like
write the spec, write the plan and then
implement. So, you would even have three
modes if if you do it correctly.
And then yeah. So,
that's already the last one. So,
takeaways, you got to experiment, you
got to figure out what works for you.
Like at what point can you just give it
a task and it runs with it? At what
point you want to give it a task and
write a spec first.
And then implement. Um keep giving it
feedback and iterate. So, never just
accept a bad answer.
And then really work on your process.
Like what what works best for you? What
works best for your team?
And use modes and prompts and
instructions to ingrain that.
Um there's some bonus mistakes you can
screenshot.
Yeah, please. One more. There's one
more. One more screenshot.
My modes, yes. That's how we how you end
up with problems and customers right
now. So, I got to clean this up too. And
then yeah, lastly
I mean there is there is a sweet spot
for how you define your code bases for
AI. So, you want to have
well-structured, self-explaining code.
Want to have the instructions set up.
Want to have examples in your
instructions.
I want to keep instructions updated.
So,
that's it.
That was my unplanned workshop. Thank
you for having me.
It was kind of planned. I learned about
Monday.